est-ce que vous avez pratiqué le double
jeu vous un politique qu'est ce que vous
appelez le double jeu des promesses
électorales la langue de bois les
magouilles les affaires alors pas du
tout c'est dans quel mouvement vous je
suis au rpr au
rfc à moussa c'est connu c'est koné
je démarre démarre faire vos preuves bon
on va se tutoyer ce sera plus conviviale
ok donc tu penses que toi il ya trop de
double jeu dans la politique ou ayant un
double jeu est ce que pour faire des
[ __ ] est il faut coucher pour réussir
je connais pas ça
avait il fallait cocher avec toute la
population je crois que il faut un
nouveau langage il faut une nouvelle vue
de la france il faut un patriotisme de
son pays et de la défense des intérêts
alors on coupe tout et je me bats pour
était mignonne
le double jeu en politique pour quoi
pour vous c'est quoi double jeu monsieur
il faut pas le jouer
le jouet vous monsieur jamais joué aux
jurés on va parler plus vrai plus direct
on va tutoyer c'est plus convivial au
qu'est ce que tu penses du double jeu
toi c'est à dire les magouilles tout ça
tu as touché toi tu as touché les yeux
dans les yeux nom de quoi donc jamais
fait quoi mais des enveloppes sous la
table on voit que le dessus y a pas d'
enveloppe qui passent en dessous mais
vous n'avez que ça à dire aux hommes
politiques le double géopolitique pour
vous c'est quoi je ne sais pas je ne
pratique pas edward une pratique un peu
il est vrai que les français n'aiment
pas toujours entendre un certain nombre
de vérités et qu' ils ont souvent au
bout du compte les parlementaires qui le
méritent et là tout le monde a décroché
à votre phrase était longue c'est
peut-être un petit peu ça aussi la
langue de bois no non parce que on ne
résume pas une situation par des
formules très court par des gros titres
à sensation non je crois que les gens
notre côté on n'a pas compris une drogue
de ce que vous avez dit c'est vous qui
lui soit vous qui le dites moi je ne
sous estime pas l'intelligence des
français et la capacité qu'ils ont de
comprendre des phrases ou qui n'est pas
capable de comprendre des phrases donc
moi je n'y peux rien essayons le trac
accessible toi raconte et crack
qu'est ce que c'est que ce vocabulaire
des villes vous alimentez je crois
effectivement toute cette cette sorte
d'attitude à la fois ironique critique
ça l'islam à l'égard de fonctionnaires y
compris votre agressivité dans des cas
rares pourrait coûter six breaks et je
décroche je m'excuse je décroche broussy
je déconne mais le journalisme
rock'n'roll non on va leur faire on va
se tutoyer c'est plus convivial c'est
comment votre prénom robert ok je vais
t'appeler bobby bobby bobby le double je
t'en penses quoi bon j'en pense peu de
choses mon paulo
la ville est double et à pasqua ne
l'offre a dit pas ce double jeu et je
pense que c'est pas du tout ce qui fait
gagner en politique écoutez rock'n'roll
ta g c'est pas de conneries le moins
possible et ainsi ma vie les régimes qui
pratiquent la langue de bois c'est
dégueulasse le point là non c'est des
pellicules on sait pas trop chier dans
la creuse ses patrons se fait pas chier
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça parce
que je n'ai moi je vous invite ont fait
du bon boulot
tu as envie ben quoi vous organisez des
clubs puisque kings ambiance qu'est ce
que c'est que les activités ou paillade
et l'activité web concrètement tous les
industriels touristiques culturelles
tout ce que vous voulez
dans la creuse oui aussi le connais je
voulais frais voire vingt six enfants
ciao
demain je vais pas bouffer annoncera
père présentez-vous bernard charreyre
député des yvelines de quel groupe vous
êtes du groupe socialiste c'est heavy
metal enfin nantes un bon groupe mais
pourquoi pas vous êtes député depuis
combien de temps dix ans est-ce que
c'est plus facile quand on est député
pour se tirer des conseils parce que ça
aide ça je pense que cela dépende pas du
rôle de
de la profession que l'on fait quand on
est député est ce que c'est plus facile
avec les gonzesses après pour conclure
coûté ce n'est pas une question sérieuse
posée une question sur la fin il faut
vous remettre en question pour moi
sérieuse parce que des fois on est sur
un coup on est sérieux on est à deux
doigts et l'ananas e4 je comprends pas
du tout son soutien parfois il est là
qui sont impressionnés d'aynac on
n'aurait pas pensé me retirer mais comme
on le député hop on peut leur mettre une
cartouche c'est une plaisanterie non
c'est une vraie question messieurs juste
une question vous vous teniez la main ce
qu'il y a des relations homosexuelles
parmi les hommes politiques
des rapports
ou ce n'est pas la main d'abord si vous
êtes caresser un petit peu vous avez eu
un début des jeux vous avez
une question jean-pierre quand on est
connu c'est plus facile avec les
gonzesses que c'est plus difficile si
forcément plus difficile parce qu'il met
des lunettes noires vraiment une
question quand on est un homme politique
est ce que c'est plus facile avec les
gonzesses après
d'abord d'abord pourquoi me tutoyez
alors est-ce que je t'aime bien bon vous
devrez sympathique en a pas on n'a pas
vécu ensemble comme ça parce que j'ai
pas voulu il est temps semble donc je
suis la barrière le député maire de pau
et vous avez payé d'attouchements
sexuels avec j'adore yvette et je crois
que ça vaut mieux la doré que tout le
reste le travail est qu'elle est bonne
mais il va être jeté pas jacques
simplement est ce que le fait d'être
connu en politique ça sert avec les
conseils
c'est à dire que depuis
que je rencontré ma femme
qui est fantastique
alors les gonzesses ne me concerne plus
plu du tout tu t'es fait couper par
avait tout faux pas du tout vraiment on
se tutoie pas alors un
pas mais on se vouvoie pas voilà dit on
ne parle pas chez ben voilà pas
rock'n'roll 1
on est tous une langue de bois mais à
les entendre ils s'en servent jamais
ouais et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu